[Music]
what's up guys mark and Charis here as
you may have heard Chris and Milka
Burkham have been hosting some live
typography critiques right here on our
Academy Channel
they've been packed with some pretty
good lessons now if you don't have time
to watch everything don't worry we've
got you covered
coming up we've got four tips from
critique number two that you can use to
improve your typography today check it
out what makes this layout beautiful if
you look at it look at this space not
just the typography so this this work we
have medium background space and then we
have large space and then next below
that we have a large space and then
below that you have this small space so
if you go below the text so that's
what's making this piece work you see
that so you have medium you have small
medium and large and you don't want to
have it go in that order you don't want
to be small medium large you do want to
play around with it you don't have it
large me as small and the medium
in the hands of a talented typographer
you can see how information can be
manipulated readjusted and configured to
whatever you want all right so this is
the list made into a paragraph and lists
typically are not presented this way and
it makes it a little bit harder to read
but it creates a different block and
shape of information and like we showed
you guys before you can adjust this and
change the column width and you can take
this and free it and make it like a list
like this and so this has yet a
different feeling because this is rather
horizontal where this is vertical and
we're gonna have challenges with the
longest name Joseph Mueller Brockman and
that's gonna dictate how this feels okay
whereas Milko was talking before about
the rag the rag right here with lists
like this you can there's nothing you
can do you're not you're not really
supposed to change their name but
everywhere else you want to control this
okay as you're doing that so these these
are kind of like my cupboard where I
have all my ingredients laid out so it's
a lot easy for me to work with so I have
a list now and I've broken the names
into first and last which makes it twice
as tall as this you can see that maybe
even taller and then I could make the
list look like this breaking into column
view and then the last thing I wanted to
show you was the first and last name
broken apart shown as three columns
right so they all have different
feelings
how do you fix or treat rag so you were
talking about how the rag you know can
change the way that you visibly look at
the pattern of words yeah so you want to
do something like my type instructor
Simon Johnson I didn't have Rebecca
Mendez he talked about it being evenly
uneven so it kind of undulates it goes
in and it goes out but isn't create
sharp lines it doesn't create weird
faces or mountaintops or things like
that su3 will make a pattern so on the
third one if you're able to to force a
paragraph break then you're able to do
so and in some words you can hyphenate
to kind of control the rag and that's
what you do
and since we're only dealing with one
page a lot of tricks you can do you can
change the width of the column of the
paragraph so making a wider or narrower
and that will resolve a lot of your
problems until you get a more pleasant
looking at your rag I tend to go to
something that's maybe but you said it's
more to the right and goes too much to a
visually interesting thing but I always
find that I'm struggling with keeping it
legible and readable so your advice
would be to make it quote unquote more
boring and try to contain myself into
making too many tricks and stuff come on
right yeah so here's what I'm gonna use
an analogy cuz I'm gonna try to chana
channel my inner Milka hair I'm gonna
use a minute let's pretend like you have
this most amazing spice it could be
chilies it could be saffron
it could be truffle oil something and
you're like this is delicious or even a
fat like pork fat right you know I love
and then can you could you imagine like
the proportion of a BLT sandwich a bacon
lettuce tomato sandwich it's a lot of
stuff and a little bit of bacon and the
contrast between the bread the tankiness
of the mayonnaise the crisps
the lice berg lettuce and the tomatoes
really complements the salty fatty part
of the bacon what people are trying to
do is like bacon and they smother it all
over the place and then you eat it you
just like whoa this is gross I feel
gross afterwards okay so a little bit of
spice a little bit of an accent or
really rich ingredient the Flair that
the the right meaning the crazy designed
expressive experimental typography use a
little bit of it because it goes a
really long way that's what I want you
to think about imagine what's gonna
happen next as we move forward and we
add more things like lines and all
different kinds of point sizes and
weights and shapes and texture what else
do you have left and now what are gonna
do during that phase you're gonna make
it really tight and boring work within
the constraints make sure it's really
legible that there's good use of space
negative space in particular and then I
feel like it's a little bit boring let
me try this one thing and that's what's
gonna do it I see the same thing
happening with logo designers too many
tricks everything that you have in your
arsenal as a designer you just shove
into that logo and this is why the
design doesn't age well you look at it
like right now it's okay and over time a
goof
so master the foundation the principles
the bones of the house are strong the
foundation is really solid a little win
is gonna knock it off and it's not gonna
knock it over where you go crazy throw a
little paint on it do some interesting
tile work that's really where you want
to spend that energy if you want to
learn more about typography you can
check out the typography critiques that
we're doing right here on the future
Academy Channel and if you really want
to dive deep we have a typography course
that you can find on our website the
future com enrolling in the course also
gives you the opportunity to submit your
work for any live critiques conducted by
Cristo
you